well uh oh we can spoil we can spoil
things
they they really deserve a good uh a
good ending whether they like it or not
they deserve closure
and uh and i think that that was given
so
i i am happy with it to see it end in
this place that is
like the happily ever after the peaceful
sort of setting where they can just sort
of carry out their days
you know um making out and stuff like i
think that it's
absolutely lovely i'm not sure what
happened
[Music]
i'm so bummed that the series is ending
after part four that wasn't the
original plan of course karen how are
you feeling about parts four
serving as the series finale and and
what can you tease about what was
supposed to happen
i am feeling uh you know
you feel a million different things when
you dedicate your life to something for
a few years and then it comes to a close
but i will say that i think we handled
the last few episodes as if they were
the last
episodes so people are going to get
closure
and they're going to get a satisfactory
ending that doesn't feel like it was
just cut off
unnecessarily uh i am
just very very glad that we approached
that finale like it was a true finale
because i think
you never know we didn't have a pickup
so we may as well have been you know
shooting a finale so it made sense to
actually
uh do so and i'm happy that we did
because i think the fans
who have been dedicated and enthusiastic
beyond belief for these past few years
they deserve that
they they really deserve a good uh a
good ending whether they like it or not
they deserve closure
and uh and i think that that was given
so
i am happy with it
in part four nick dropped the otp
bombshell by saying that sabrina and
nick
are end game given how this season ends
how do you feel about their relationship
now well
uh oh we can spoil we can spoil things
yes excellent
uh this is a long time commonly and i
feel like this
um this love has been driven by the
fandom truly
uh we often see how people are shipping
who with who and
um and writers listen to that creatives
listen to that and we look at that
and eat it up just as much as they do
and
i was tentative at first i felt like i
was kind of coming into
a relationship of harvey and sabrina and
i was breaking that up
however sabrina nick's love goes through
so many trials and tribulations and i
really think that relationships that
can withstand the good the bad and the
ugly really are
something real and special you know
sabrina and harvey had something that
was pure and
lovely in its in its youth and nick and
sabrina had something that was
really sort of tough like they had to
work at eventually loving each other and
work at
being able to trust each other again so
to see it end in this place that is
like the happily ever after the peaceful
sort of setting where they can just sort
of carry out their days
you know um making out and stuff like i
think that it's
absolutely lovely sabrina is that you
well there you are where were you we
were getting worried
not me i haven't been worried since
bottomless mimosas
we got a bewitching surprise when the
aunts
from sabrina the teenage witch caroline
rhea and beth broderick
made a surprise cameo how did this
crossover come about
i mean i couldn't tell you how it came
about because in the script it was so
vague
i don't think that they wanted to uh get
their hopes up
so i think when the script was
originally sent out to all of us they
didn't
have the antis secured yet so it's like
sabrina steps into another universe and
we see two familiar faces
and uh i was like is this really what
we're gonna are we really gonna get
these guys
and they were delightful and lovely and
it just felt like
absolute kismet like we should
definitely
not uh leave this show in this world
without
bringing in the og's oh yeah
so i was i was delighted well do you
ever think that we could revisit this
character in a movie do you have
anything that's still
on your sabrina bucket list you never
got to tackle you never got to go to the
town over
i want her to go to riverdale i've said
this all that i say this
all the time but i would love to just
those kids need help they need help
they're struggling without
magic look they're dealing with a lot
and i just think it would be like really
nice of her if she were to go like
help them out a little bit i mean
riverdale's not canceled yet so i feel
like could we see you go on to their
show
i'm down someone's just gotta call me
and tell me to do it
i'll be there i'll be there
in a heartbeat